hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen beim
neuen video heute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut auf jeden fall haben wir
gerade schon halb zwölf ich war gestern
noch ein bisschen so im internet
unterwegs wie einen namen habe mir halt
auch so dass eine andere youtube video
angeschaut und irgendwo kann man halt so
eine werbung und zwar wurde der song
macdonald hot dog vorgestellt ich dachte
ich kann euch das ganze gerne mal zeigen
das müsste hier dieses hot dogs sein
sieht eigentlich ganz lecker aus und
kostet wohl nur 1 euro alter
kriegskamerad draufgehen
hallo hinweg den vertrag mit knackiger
wo ist in einem knusprigen bla bla bla
und ich habe mir an dieser stelle fairer
weise gedacht da ich ja schon mal den
burger king hat probiert haben den es
damals irgendwann mal gab es kurze
ausschnitt sieht zum anbeißen lecker aus
da will man am liebsten nur über
schlabbern muss ich jetzt auch mal den
berg donnerstag ausprobieren ich kann
mich auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen
daran erinnern wie das geschmeckt hat
nur wir waren ja letztens auch
irgendwann bei ikea und haben da
eingekauft und ich glaube denn ikea hat
auch zu schlagen ist schon schwer
also geht es mal wieder zu den mcdonald
meines vertrauens um die ecke und weiß
ich noch mal kurz sagen wollte am
sonntag kommt ein mega mehr krasses
video hier noch mal ein ganz kurzer
ausschnitt
wir haben auf jeden fall echt mega lange
dran gesessen deswegen ja sonntag 11 uhr
morgens gibt es das video
seit gespannt
so wir sind jetzt da ich hoffe nur ich
krieg den hier auch das wir sonst ein
bisschen blöd und dazu noch so
hot dog
wenn er das war's so hat sich ganz gut
angehört den hot gibt es mit
[Musik]
so leute ich bin jetzt wieder zurück ich
werde etwas voll bepackt und das wort
hat mega schwer hier die tür aufzumachen
mit all den sachen könnte man bitte kurz
in die kommentare schreiben
soll ich meine haare so naturfarben
lassen euch die blond färben oder mal
drauf haben schreibt mir das auf jeden
fall meine kommentare also einfach grau
oder normal meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen
zu offiziellen alex wie hot dog test
kannst du mal eine motorsäge ausmachen
so leute also ich bin mal gespannt
ja also das hier ist eine wunderschöne
verpackung der mcdonald's hat ich würde
sagen wir machen niemals auf also da hat
sich aber jemand nicht viel mühe gehen
würde
heute wird man mal schaut da hat jemand
einfach das ganze was eigentlich
obendrauf muss drucker getan ja also
sich das ganze haus ist natürlich jetzt
kein meisterwerk vom optisch mehr aber
an sich sollte es ja der geschmack
machen also dass deutschland fühlt sich
ziemlich cool also ähnlich wie kies
bürger brötchen würde ich das
beschreiben oder einfach jedes brötchen
was man dazu bekommt und ich würde sagen
nachdem jetzt alle fleißigen kommentar
geschrieben habt wieder in meine neue
haarfarbe aussehen soll
probieren wir das mal
[Musik]
mir fällt gerade auch wieder außer dass
hier heute noch gar nichts gegessen das
ist praktisch mein frühstück vor die hot
zum frühstück war die leute einmal noch
echte type der motorsäge regt mich ja so
auf ne also leute die irgendwie erst mal
schön
ich muss sagen schon jetzt übertreibt
nicht in der lage
also ich glaube in den nächsten zwei
stunden nicht mal so ich muss aber sagen
es ist an sich einem standard hot dog
wenn man bock hat und begründete so ein
hotdog essen will kann man sich halt
jetzt einkaufen von optischen her ist es
jetzt nicht so der berner wenn man hier
sieht ist alles so ein bisschen verklebt
dann auch aber das klingt schmeckt auf
jeden fall ganz gut ich werde kann man
sich da auf jeden fall eher weniger ist
es gerade dein ernst dicker was machst
du da sind nicht mal blätter leute
seitdem ich hier wohne hat hier noch nie
jemand glaubt weg gemacht und jetzt wenn
ich einmal ein video drehen macht jemand
glaubt beck also wenn man dann erstmal
mit dem ikea oder zum beispiel
vergleichen waren der verzweigung bei
ikea und haben noch unsere wohnung des
hin eingerichtet muss ich auf jeden fall
sagen dass der nicht so gut ist aber
wenn man sich jetzt selber einen hotdog
macht kommen dass ungefähr vergleichen
also den jetzt zu probieren lohnt sich
nicht wirklich aber wenn man hunger
drauf hat krawall zu machen und ich habe
auf jeden fall schon bessere gegessen wo
auch denke ich mal ein bisschen mehr
liebe drin steckt ach so ganz vergessen
zu sagen das teil hat jetzt sich nur
einen euro kostet sondern plötzlich 190
warum auch immer steht nicht so auf der
internetseite oben drüber steht eine
grundversorgung ab 1 euro und hier steht
doch mal ein euro dran was wirklich ein
euro kostet ja ja ich weiß ich erst
jetzt natürlich noch auf und ich hoffe
meine test hat euch ein bisschen
unterhalten
ich mache irgendwie in letzter zeit so
was ziemlich oft lassen dann nach oben
dafür mehr abonnieren nicht vergessen
und wir sehen uns dann morgen
morgen gibt es nämlich dem trailer zu
dem video das sonntag raus kommen auf
keinen fall verpassen
jak sda münster gemacht aber drei einen
schönen tag hieß